okay so the amazing spider-man 2 is a
film where the things surrounding it are
just as interesting as the movie itself
released in a time when the mcu was
really taking off it was critically
panned for having too many villains
subplots and a weird score that has the
singer basically giving electros in a
monologue garfield's web head had a
tough time from the beginning and his
version of peter parker was released
just five years after the toby maguire
incarnation before he himself was
replaced by holland's spider-man less
than 4 years after because of this the
amazing spider-man franchise is often
overlooked but it has picked up a strong
following online who absolutely loved
the film when you watch it you can kind
of see why too and though it has its low
points there's also a scene in it that i
think is absolutely perfect not that one
not not the one with jamie foxx making
himself a birthday cake from spider-man
no what i'm talking about is gwen
stacy's death ever since it was
announced that emma stone would be
playing the role in the amazing
spider-man we knew that the character
was truly doomed and this franchise very
much built up to that moment coming to
fruition for many years gwen's death was
viewed as a defining moment for the
character and though she's been brought
back to life in recent times for several
decades it was said that she should be a
character that remained dead like uncle
ben and the waynes gwen stacy's death
very much represents a number of things
in peter's life and to me the amazing
spider-man 2 absolutely nailed all of
these aspects peter parker is someone
who was plucked out of queens and given
incredible abilities that transformed
him into a superhuman
initially he wanted to use these gifts
for personal gain but after they
inadvertently led to the death of his
uncle ben he decided that he would
instead use them to help others peter
donned his spider-man costume to keep
those around him safe and he tried to
have a normal life being a vigilante
caused several runs with the law
including captain stacy stacy was killed
in the comics and the source material
had him saying in his final breath that
he should take care of gwen this
somewhat is the opposite to the amazing
spider-man franchise as cap was very
much like stay away from my daughter and
also like the video but either way you
look at it peter broke his promise
though he tried to keep gwen safe and
protector wanting things for his own
personal gain and happiness ultimately
led to him losing once more in the
comics green goblin took gwen to the top
of the brooklyn bridge and clocked her
with his glider which sent her hurtling
over the edge reacting quickly peter
fired a web around her ankles in order
to catch her but upon climbing down he
realized that she was dead for many
years peter didn't know whether it was
the impact of the goblin or the whiplash
from the webbing that ended her life and
he spent a long time dealing with the
guilt over this it was revealed later in
the comics that it was indeed the
webbing that broke her neck but i've
always been someone who viewed peter as
doing the best he could in the situation
and to me the fault lay with norman i
was born for putting her in that
position peter being peter though he
very much blamed himself and believed
that because he chose to be spider-man
that he's the one who put the woman he
loved in danger there's definitely a
debate to be had there and that's what
makes the character so interesting he's
someone who will try and do the best he
can but even doing the best he can can
often mean that those he loves die
because of it peter parker is an
extremely flawed character that fails
like the rest of us and that's what
makes him so relatable now whatever you
think of the amazing spider-man movies i
think most people agree that peter and
gwen's relationship was the strongest
part of those films andrew garfield and
emma stone dated in real life and that
chemistry definitely comes across in the
characters who go back and forth
throughout the two movies peter very
much wrestles with whether to keep his
promise to captain stacy or to follow
his heart and to be with the woman that
he loves in the film gwen gets a chance
at another life in london and peter in
the end decides to go with her to
england however the happy moment is
ruined by electro who starts to drain
power from the city gwen's death is even
foreshadowed here as the two stand on
top of a bridge which is of course where
the character died in the comics peter
webbs went to a car in order to keep her
safe but she ends up joining him in
stopping the electrical enemy gwen is
just as much of a genius as peter well
well probably even smarter and she knows
the grid specs in and out making her a
valuable asset in trying to stop max
from playing the incy wincy spider on
peter's head they managed to stop him
and send him to the mcu which is when
the green goblin swoops in cackling i
absolutely love the screeching of the
glider and though dain dahan's goblin
gets a lot of crap i think using the
actor's face instead of having a mask
works really well after his father's
death harry learned that he was dying
from a debilitating disease and he tried
to reach out to spider-man in order to
help find a cure however getting a blood
sample from oscorp labs led him into
mutating even further and thus he sought
revenge gwen was very much caught in the
crossfire and as the two battled in the
clock tower she was left dangling by a
thread as the pair battled it out as all
the gears came crashing down we got a
brilliant moment in which her literal
lifeline was cut and this leads to her
arm dropping before the rest of her body
does i'm not sure if the physics behind
this are right but it's such a cool shot
that made me get butterflies in my
stomach the first time that i watched it
you really get that sinking feeling as
gwen starts to fall and peter leaps down
the tower after her throughout the
spider-verse films we've often seen the
usage of a reflection in the eyes of
either spider-man or venom in which
they're trying to stop someone from
falling to their death we really get the
desperation peter faces here and seeing
her reflected in his eyes very much
reflects how much she means to him
there's a lot of subtle iconography here
too such as the web peter shoots out to
her itself resembling a hand reaching
out to save her and he watches it fires
through the gears of barely managing to
catch her now her death is of course one
of the most famous in all comic book
history so we know what's coming but
when analyzing the scene the creative
team do an incredible job of using the
scoring setting to make us think there's
a chance that peter will save gwen just
as gwen falls they tune everything out
and leave a solitary piano so that we
can truly see how focused peter is on
saving her though he was just attempting
to stop the goblin this soul instrument
blocks out everything else and makes it
so that we too just focus on her the
gears also cover her at one point so
that we can't see gwen but these open up
as the web shoots down giving us the
idea that all the obstacles have cleared
out the way and that he's actually going
to save her unfortunately though as the
web hits her he grabs the pipe and this
causes it to tighten which whips her
head backwards this cracks off the
ground and the snap from it is even more
impactful than the one carried out by
thanos they completely cut the music and
all the other effects so that all you
hear is this sound and i remember it
shaking through the cinema when i saw it
for the first time add to this the clock
which two breaks symbolizing that gwen's
time is up and you have a lot of things
laced throughout the subtext that makes
this moment hit 10 times harder in the
aftermath of it you could hear a pin
drop and though we knew this was coming
it was completely devastating to see it
play out hammering this moment home is
andrew garfield who drops down and gives
a performance that reminded me of bambi
finding his mother dead there's just
something so innocent to it that it
makes it even more devastating as with a
lot of spider-man movies we end with a
funeral but something about this one
feels ever more personal we dealt with a
lot of characters dying around peter but
watching the montage of him at a grave
as the seasons pass makes it hit home 10
times harder this truly captures the
grief that he's going through and lets
us know how impactful this was
spider-man is someone who's often seen
as a kitty character who's somewhat
cartoonish because of his big eyes and
brightly coloured costumes however he
can really have moments like this that
are real gut punches that make you
realize the kind of battles that peter
is truly fighting not only does he have
to tackle super criminals but he also
has to deal with losing those around him
he's not a billionaire he's not
invincible and he's not someone who ever
has it easy added this he broke captain
stacy's promise and the guy is just
taking constant l's and that's not the
only thing he's breaking eh
sorry about that
really bad now peter even quits being
spider-man but in the end it's the
memory of gwen that brings him back
around in the final few scenes he speaks
to ant-may who's putting ben's stuff in
a box she says the heavier the box is
the lighter she feels which very much
speaks to the acceptance part of grief
and learning to let go though she isn't
chucking it out because it's part of her
she's finding a better place for it
peter plays gwen's graduation speech in
which he's told to hold on to hope and
to become that she says that even if we
fail to try and become that which very
much summarizes her death and peter's
next step much like may he puts gwen's
possessions in a box but leaves one
photo behind as a reminder and he
returns his spider-man say what you want
about the film but i feel like this rise
and fall of the character represents why
we as audiences love him so much he is a
person who's been through some of the
worst things imaginable and though he's
lost people close to him he will still
come back every time gwen's death is
obviously a tragedy but it's such an
intrinsic part of the character that
shows his greatest strength is dealing
with his own failures and coming back
from them though i do have some issues
with the film i think gwen's death is
one of the most impactful scenes in a
comic book movie ever and that's why
that scene is absolutely perfect
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it so make sure you comment
below and let me know we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the spider-man 4k
trilogies on the 30th of december all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the scene we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of spiderman
no way home which will be linked on
screen right now we've talked about all
the tv spots all the trailers so it's
definitely worth checking out right
after this without the way thank you for
singing through the video i've been poor
i'll see you in the next one take care
peace